[Music]
truck as you may or may not know I'm
always been fascinated with television
love television you have somehow hit the
sweet spot I think you've created
I said two-thirds of the television
shows on the air right now not just in
this country but globally and on other
planets incredible an incredible success
and I understand I'm mostly interested
in how people get started how they get
their foot in the door you got started
in TV because you were a door-to-door
salesman is that right right I was going
door-to-door selling Christmas crap
Christmas well it didn't help that you
called it Christmas crowd probably do
you put some Christmas called it radios
but yeah I wound up getting a job in
animation but how does that work you're
selling door-to-door and it feels like
you just knocked on a door where they
happen to be working in television or
had every door I knocked on I asked for
a job is it did you really pretty much
you guys in show business can I come in
yeah that was that man yeah he's funny
you you're joking but I actually tell
young people who ask me how do you get
started in TV I say go to where they
make TV and then do anything like you've
sweep up well not anything work for me
but you so you go door-to-door and there
was a place that made animation and you
just said please give me a shot I said
what do you guys do here they said we're
making cartoons I said you do funny
stuff and they said yeah I said I'm your
man
I had no idea what I was talking about I
didn't know how to do animation I'd
never seen an animated script before I
was faking it
yeah clearly faking they gave me a job I
love that you also use the phrase I'm
your man which is something that you see
in movies but you think nobody really
says that it was 1987 it was current fun
so okay what what what what work did you
do I know that you did different
animated shows can you give us like when
you start it out
Heathcliff the cat you worked on
Heathcliff did you get the cat yeah okay
Muppet Babies you worked on Muppet
Babies well I kind of got fired from the
Muppets you can't fire that is a badge
of honor you were fired my babies I just
didn't have the the Miss Piggy thing
going what about my little pony is it
true that I can Don that one too you got
fired from my little pony didn't have
this star dust star speckle you could
use some bad words go for it TBS man no
idea if you want to be if you want to
rip my little pony a new a-hole go right
for it